well whoa whoa people here call it camp
despair the krinar refugee camp was set
up more than 20 years ago for people
displaced by the conflicts in the
balkans nowadays refugees are arriving
from Pakistan northern Africa or like
fame order Somalia he says he arrived
months ago and is now stuck here only
Iraqis and Syrians are allowed to travel
on to the European Union to apply for
asylum but fahim does not want to return
home Aloha Mahalo heart when I was born
Somalia was already at war I only know
the beauty of Africa from films on
television in powerful people are
starving where I come from I was hit by
shrapnel I still had the scars on my
stomach the gist Africa this Serbian
couple do janka and melon Kiev elitsa
fled their home in the chi inna region
300 kilometers away more than two
decades ago relations with crow hats in
their home village were peaceful but
then the war began creation soldiers
destroyed their home and they had to
flee yes I need to be immersed in the
books when we got here oh well that was
a horse blanket nobody helped us start a
new life we got no money or any other
kind of assistance I forgot to attend
the dinner and even memory they have
been here ever since living in cramped
conditions oh there we get we have
everything in this one room here's the
kitchen here's the living room well then
here's the bedroom all I old doctor who
needs a boy after was I don't remember
even prisons have better buns and we
store things under the beds more than a
hundred refugees from the Balkans war in
the 1990s are still living here
in recent months they have got to know
new neighbors from remote lands nada
fahim o de melon and ushanka have become
friends at least I start to learn this
family what about why they stay here
what are they doing here then I start to
greet them for one day great they called
me too I drink a fight they start to
love me and I start to love them seem
like my family I wanna marry Sam LaRocca
a taco he told me about his family and
how his mother died I felt so sorry for
him what a situation to be your demeanor
tell me the least we can do is be there
for him and to listen to mr. me to talk
with some chanukah go so Mora more
cheaply what Allah so they try to cheer
each other up under depressing
circumstances hbu um they've all been
here government officials journalists
ambassadors human rights organizations
Oh buddy Danny pathetic a homeowner down
the other than he died yeah during their
visits they promised us the moon boy but
once they've gone all that is soon
forgotten on it really time nothing ever
changes we can t click an image
we asked the camp's director how he sees
the situation this one is the stuff it's
quite simple we never had any money for
years and years we had no budget but now
we are feeling more optimistic about to
camp sekai-ichi the European Union has
promised to help score near close on
others we hope to have a solution to the
problems en place by the springs the
traveler dr. Suresh but in the meantime
more and more refugees are arriving
these men are from Pakistan they don't
have any money so they can't pay people
smugglers to sneak them into an EU
country they asked for him how they can
move on from here and get to the west
yeah his answer is sobering the Croats
will deport you the Austrians will
deport you you don't stand a chance I am
staying here for now a few days ago for
him went into Belgrade to apply for
asylum here in Serbia it was not an easy
decision for him to make Serbia is still
suffering from the aftermath of the
Civil War the economy is weak few
applicants are granted asylum Habibullah
de yoga I'm frightened I could get stuck
in account forever like my two friends I
want to study i want to learn languages
i want to have my own home and have a
family maybe i'll try again later to get
into the European Union as a musical for
now all fahim do janka and milan can do
is wait and hope that one day they can
escape the camp of despair
you